ici on est dans la chambre de François
je suis famille d'accueil j'accueille
trois personnes François a fait un AVC
juste avant d'être à la retraite il y a
quoi il y a 3 ans
sa sœur a cherché un accompagnement
personnalisé parce que François a que 60
ans et elle avait pas envie qui
finissent dans un EHPAD c'est bon tu as
tout ce qu'il te faut et j'ai été
animatrice en EHPAD pendant trois ans et
moi j'avais envie de créer un lieu de
vie pour personnes âgées de trouver un
intermédiaire à ses EHPAD qui sont
beaucoup trop gros et on n'a pas
vraiment le temps de prendre soin des
personnes qui qui sont là qui ont passé
toute leur vie à travailler et quand
elles sont deux pour coucher 80
personnes c'est pas possible
impeccable super
tac et là on a bêtis on est dans le
petit salon qui est pour eux il est où
en haut tu vas le chercher alors ici on
vit tous ensemble c'est le but de la
famille d'accueil c'est à dire que là
c'est la pièce commune cuisine salle à
manger on prend les repas en commun
c'est vraiment la vie de famille vivre
avec nous après moi j'ai mon espace
privé j'ai un autre salon de l'autre
côté pour être avec mes enfants parce
que la famille d'accueil oui c'est du
H24 on est tous ensemble on partage
notre vie avec eux parce que c'est le
but c'est pas pour qu'il soit en chambre
tout seul mais c'est important aussi de
garder de l'intimité que ce soit pour
eux et pour nous ils savent que à partir
19h30 à part si c'est un cas d'extrême
urgence forcément oui je vais y aller
mais sinon à 19h30 tout le monde sait
que c'est pour mes enfants ma famille
pour moi et que moi aussi j'ai le droit
de faire stop même si je suis chez moi
et que c'est du H24
tu joues avec eux Hugo vas-y pour moi
c'est mon plus gros avantage pour avoir
grandir mes enfants tout en travaillant
et en prenant soin des personnes que
j'agrine j'ai du temps pour vous ou pas
les 400 coups avec François j'ai une
vidéo où François a accroché derrière
son fauteuil électrique le tracteur des
enfants avec la remorque et il faisait
tout le tour dehors avec les enfants
comme ça
faut bien les occuper
tu es foutu
impeccable
et je leur ai expliqué que j'allais
faire famille d'accueil que j'allais
accueillir des personnes mais que si ça
se passait mal ou que si ça allait pas
avec tel ou telle personne enfin voilà
que rien n'était figé que on pouvait
discuter que il fallait un temps
d'adaptation que ce soit pour la
personne qui arrive parce que la
personne qui arrive aussi en perte
d'Europe parce qu'elle quitte son
domicile ou l'hôpital ou l'EHPAD comme
François qui du jour au lendemain a fait
un AVC et on lui a dit bah tu peux plus
rentrer chez toi
tu vas chercher Yvette
tu vas lui demander si elle veut peler
les légumes pour la soupe dans une
journée je passe de la casquette de
maman à cuisinière travailleuse femme de
ménage et de soignante il faut savoir
accepter les années
avec le sourire
c'est tellement mieux et souris tout le
temps il va être amené sa commode à
amener à ces cadres et la recréer son
son petit chez soi ici pour se sentir
pour se sentir bien
c'est bon on est passé merci Chef
c'est bon c'est bien impeccable
[Applaudissements]
tiens regarde je t'ai mis ton économe
la famille d'accueil c'est aussi
maintien de l'autonomie
quand on voit François quand il est
arrivé et quand on voit François
maintenant tout le monde me dit il est
méconnaissable j'y vais aussi il veut
être appris en agilité et
je reconnais que en plein de choses
c'est une ambiance
classique
et enrichissant parce que il y a le
sourire des enfants
et puis on plaisante
voilà
c'est bon tu es bien comme ça
elle vivait avec son papa et sa maman et
il y a trois ans son papa est décédé sa
maman est allée en EHPAD et à 61 ans
être dans un EHPAD sa cousine qui est sa
tutrice c'est un concevable
moi aussi
l'accueil familial ça a quand même
limite je vais accueillir jusqu'à la fin
de vie si j'ai les capacités et les
ressources pour arriver à le faire après
il y a une différence entre accompagner
jusqu'à la fin de vie et avoir une
personne qui
de par son ses troubles du comportement
et de sa maladie va se mettre en danger
le jour la nuit ou là ça nécessite un
accompagnement dans des structures
protégées des structures fermées je
connais aussi mes limites et j'adore le
métier que je fais mais faut savoir dire
stop et là les EHPAD prennent le relais
mais si le métier de famille d'accueil
était plus connu plus valorisé que les
gens savaient qu'il y avait cette
alternative en fait on un tremplin pour
pour soit les pâtes soit pas du tout les
pad